[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELISSE ROCHE: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to the "Data
for Good" session on driving
social and environmental impact
with data analytics.
My name is Elisse Roche,
and I lead our initiatives
around data for social
and environmental impact
here at Google Cloud.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN:
Thanks, Elise.
Thanks, everyone,
for being here.
I'm Alonso Ortiz, the
community engagement manager
for the Global Partnership for
Sustainable Development Data.
Global Partnership is
a network committed
to ensure we have the necessary
data to achieve DSDGs.
ELISSE ROCHE: And what
we're really looking forward
to discussing here today
are the opportunities
to apply data analytics
and machine-learning
to a variety of issues and to
solving some of the world's
greatest challenges.
In addition to that, also
speaking to some of the use
cases that we're currently
seeing with non-profits who
are using our
solutions, and also
an initiative that we
collaborate on together
around data visualization.
So, we thought before
digging a little bit deeper
into what Google Cloud
is doing in this space
and what the Global Partnership
team is doing in this space,
wanted to look at Data for Good
as a concept, as a movement,
and discuss how it
has evolved over time.
So, Data for Good is an
international movement
where private
companies are working
with governmental agencies,
NGOs, and nonprofits
to apply big data solutions to
some of the world's greatest
challenges.
And, dating back to
example four in 2008,
the CDC collaborated with Google
to launch Google Flu Trends,
with this idea that you could
actually look at search trends
around flu symptoms--
or similar searches
to actually help predict
outbreaks in that area.
In 2011, the United Nations
Global Pulse Organization
advocated for this idea
of data philanthropy
where organizations
that have access to data
can help make it available
for public benefit.
In 2013, the United Nations
also utilized satellite imagery
to provide targeted
disaster relief,
looking at pre-disaster
and post-disaster areas
in order to determine which
areas, communites, et cetera
needed the most support
as soon as possible.
Later in 2017, the UN hosted the
world's first World Data Forum,
the second of which
actually took place in 2018,
bringing together a variety
of different industries
to discuss, again, how we
can all better work together
across the private
and public sectors
in order to apply data analytics
to these challenging issues.
And, here we are in 2018 looking
at interdisciplinary programs
in collaboration.
And, with that, there's
the question-- so,
what exactly is Google
Cloud doing in this space?
So, Google Cloud--
here, we are working
to empower nonprofits
with integrated solutions
from geospatial analysis tools
to productivity tools to even
a nonprofit grant program.
In 2007, Google Maps helped
nonprofits access satellite
imagery and APIs with
Google Earth outreach.
In 2011, G-Suite for
nonprofits launched
with the idea of enabling
nonprofits to collaborate
and innovate together.
It's also worth noting that
those two offerings are
currently available through the
Google for Nonprofits website
and platform.
In 2016, we launched
GCP public data
sets with this idea of
democratizing access
to planetary scale
data sets that are
freely hosted in the cloud.
So, whether you're a
non-profit organization or not,
really any GCP user can
access these public data
sets and analyze them up
to one terabyte per month
at no charge.
And these include data
sets from organizations
like the EPA, the US Department
of Health and Human Services,
the World Bank, the
United Nations Statistics
Division-- the list continues.
And, in 2018, we actually
announced the Data Solutions
for Change program.
It's a nonprofit grant
program with the goal
of empowering nonprofits to
achieve their missions at scale
with data analytics.
Essentially, we understand
that with big data solutions,
nonprofits can scale their data.
They can analyze
data at the scale
of the entire web with a query.
They can automate
their work and tap
into artificial intelligence
with cloud machine-learning.
And they can also
share their vision
and turn their data into
customizable reports
with tools like
Google Data Studio.
And that's, essentially, what
underscores the Data Solutions
for Change program,
where we're looking
to address two key challenges
that nonprofits often
face when trying to access data
analytics and data analytics
solutions-- one being financial
and the other technical.
So, with the Data Solutions
for Change program,
what we're offering
includes Google credits--
a need-based Google
Cloud credit grant
depending on their
proposal-- self-training
resources through
Qwiklabs, and also
hands-on support through
Google Cloud customer
support for the duration of
their six-month grant period.
And, while this program
just launched in 2018,
we're already seeing a
variety of nonprofits
applying these solutions
in really interesting ways.
One of them is the Open
Agriculture Foundation,
where they're using BigQuery
and IoT Core in order
to create healthier, more
engaging, and more inventive
food with technology.
They've actually developed
these proprietary food computers
where they're looking
to, essentially,
develop plant codes--
plant recipe codes and
looking at different variables
so that they can
understand, for example, how
a basil plant responds
to a certain humidity
level versus lettuce.
Harambee Youth
Employment Accelerator
is a nonprofit organization
based in South Africa.
They're using BigQuery
and machine-learning
to connect more unemployed
youth in South Africa with jobs.
They understand that the
public transportation
system in South Africa can
be particularly challenging.
And so, with entry
level applicants,
they're looking at developing
a proprietary machine-learning
algorithm and a
job-matching algorithm
so that they're not only
matching these entry level
applicants with new
positions, but also
working towards job retention.
It's also worth noting
that they recently
received a social
entrepreneurship
award this year.
The Foundation for
Precision Medicine
is using BigQuery
and machine-learning
to detect Alzheimer's disease
early with the goal of stopping
the progression of the disease.
So, with Alzheimer's
in particular,
there's currently
not a cure today.
And so, a lot of
research is focused
around finding that cure.
But, what the Foundation for
Precision Medicine is doing is
they're actually taking a
bit of a different approach.
They have this idea
of, essentially,
getting ahead of a diagnosis-- a
traditional diagnosis by months
or even years so as to prescribe
preventative treatment.
Power Poetry-- a bit of a
shift towards the arts--
what they're doing is they're
using machine-learning
to increase teen literacy
through interactive
recommendation engines.
So, they've created their own
proprietary machine-learning
algorithms to match teen
submissions teen poetry
submissions with rap
artists and American poets.
BroodMinder is also
another organization
working with our technology.
And what they're
doing is they're
using Firebase and
Cloud Firestore
to manage their IoT bee
high-tracking sensors
and to improve bee
health around the US.
So, for those unfamiliar with
the state of the bee population
today, it is declining--
their health is declining.
They're facing hive collapse
around the United States.
And this is concerning not
only to the bee populations
and biodiversity more
broadly, but also
given the impact that that
may have upon our food
systems given the
importance of pollinators,
especially around
fruits and vegetables.
And one more example
to share with you
all is around biodiversity.
So, the Zoological
Society of London
is using AutoML to optimize
camera trap surveys
and to advance research
studies with that ultimate goal
of preserving biodiversity.
Camera trap surveys are an
extremely popular method
of research in this space,
and they use motion sensors.
Oftentimes, these sensors
can have false positives.
So that what you end up
with after these surveys
are thousands upon
thousands of images that
need to be manually analyzed.
As you can imagine, that's
extremely time-consuming,
so you end up having
folks with PhDs in biology
going through each
of these camera
trap images individually
over a period of months.
And what they're
working towards is
reducing that time of analysis
from months to just days.
And I'd like to share a
video that tells a bit more
about ZSL and their journey.
SOPHIE MAXWELL:
The main challenges
facing wildlife today is
habitat loss, climate change,
and threats from
illegal wildlife trade.
ZSL's mission is to create a
world where wildlife thrives.
We work in over 50
countries around the world
where we empower
and inform people,
to help stop wild
animals going extinct
we have been working
with Google to look
at how we can use Cloud AutoML
to really make a difference.
OLIVER WEARN: We use
camera traps to monitor
the state of the planet.
They are tiny little
digital cameras
hooked up to a little
motion sensor, basically.
So, when an animal
walks past, they
snap a photo, which you can
then retrieve at a later time.
As well as telling you about how
abundant different species are,
they can also offer
behavioral insights as well.
ELISSE ROCHE: One
camera trap study
generates hundreds of
thousands of images.
So, over six months, you might
get half a million images
that you need to sort
through and analyze.
SAM SECCOMBE: You've got to
go through every single image.
You've got a label them--
the time, the date, what it
contains, which camera pulls.
At the moment, it takes months.
SOPHIE MAXWELL: If we can speed
up the analysis from six months
to just days,
that's revolutionary
in our conservation effort.
Google Cloud AutoML
conservationists
who are non-coders to
use machine-learning
to create image recognition
models to identify species
in camera tracking images.
OLIVER WEARN: These are
images that I have labeled,
and they're going to teach
the AutoML algorithm what
different species look like.
SAM SECCOMBE: If you can
just AutoML it, you can go--
show me the images
that are empty,
show me the images that have the
animal that I'm interested in.
You could actually use
your scientific research
and conservation time to
do conservation rather
than doing data analysis.
SOPHIE MAXWELL: We might use
the data to actually influence
policy change or
conservation action.
AI is going to play
a really big part
in collecting all
the data together
from wildlife conservation
sites around the world.
And, if we do that
in real time, we
can use AutoML to really
monitor the pulse of wildlife
across the planet.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: So,
before I talk about the work
we do at the Global Partnership
for Sustainable Development
Data, I want to talk about
the 17 sustainable development
goals.
What you're seeing
in this light is
the result of years
of negotiations
between 193 countries.
They were agreed in 2015, and
they are to be met in 2030.
They are a framework or
a guide to take action
towards reducing poverty,
protecting the planet,
ensuring prosperous societies.
And I want to highlight for
it key things about the SDGs.
First, the fact that 193
countries agreed to something,
especially such an
inspirational framework,
successful in and of itself,
especially because they
have been widely able to
capture attention from citizens,
civil society, and companies.
So, the second aspect
that I want to highlight
is their universality.
They're not only to be
implemented by governments,
but also by other stakeholders.
And, thankfully, many have
committed to achieving them
and are adapting
and adopting them,
whether from civil society
or from the private sector.
And they're
contributing to them.
And I also want to highlight
that they're not only
to be implemented in
developing countries,
but also in development
[INAUDIBLE]..
The third thing I
want to highlight
is that even though we're
seeing individual goals,
they're all connected
to each other.
In order to achieve
long-lasting change,
we need to tackle all of
them at the same time.
For example, SDG2,
ending hunger,
is connected to SDG16 and SDG15.
So, when thinking
about ending hunger,
we need to think of land rights
and protecting the environment.
So, they're connected
to each other.
And, finally, the
architect of the SDGs--
besides giving goals--
they also left us
with 169 targets
and 233 indicators
to accompany the agenda.
And the targets can be
thought of as the objectives
and the policies that
need to be put in place.
And the indicators
are the way we
measure progress along
the way and, ultimately,
if we achieve impact.
So, however, there's a big
a missing piece in disposal,
and that's data.
Data is the lifeblood of
sustainable development.
And, in this case,
the responsibility
falls mainly in governments
who are mandated to officially
report on the SDGs.
And, as we know,
governments have a hard time
to produce timely
or real time data.
In many cases, governments
are taking decisions
with old data, or,
in some cases--
in the case of countries
afflicted by conflict,
there is no data at all.
So, that's where the work of
the Global Partnership comes in.
We're a global network
committed to ensure
we have the necessary data to
achieve and monitor the SDGs.
We were founded in 2015
alongside the sustainable
development goals,
and we bring together
governments, civil society,
UN agencies, multilaterals,
and the private sector
to collectively solve
the problems and gaps around
the production and use of data.
We don't collect or
provide the data ourselves,
we'd rather provide strategic
partnerships, advocacy,
technical assistance, and
pilot tests for our partners
at the national, regional,
and global level.
We also provide offline and
online spaces for partners
to come together and
tackle specific challenges.
For example, we set up
a SDG data collaborative
with UN statistics deviation
to work towards better
interoperability, and we
host international events
such as a Data for
Development Festival.
Finally, all the work
that we do attempts
to reduce the barriers-- the
technical barriers that there
are to have better data,
but also the political ones.
For example, I want to talk
about the Africa regional data.
And so, we're supporting five
countries in East and West
Africa to access
and use 17 years
of satellite data in order to
improve their policy-making.
And we are connecting them
with key partners such as NASA
and the Group on
Earth observations
so they can have
analysis and ready data
through an infrastructure
called a datacube.
The datacube has
many applications.
It helps governments
understand land degradation,
detect illegal binding, and
strengthen food security.
So, about a decade ago,
a country such as Kenya
would have paid approximately
$1 million per year
in order to access these data.
Harder, it is now open and
free, but the challenge
does not end with having data.
There are many
technical issues--
whole infrastructures
that need to be set up
in order to collect,
have the data,
and analyze it, and have the
necessary capacities to do so.
So, by bringing together
these five countries
through a common
infrastructure will
help them to troubleshoot
together, to take training
together, and as well to learn
from each other along the way.
And especially
having governments
at the highest level agree and
commit to this infrastructure,
we're also putting the
right political attention
so it has resources, and
there's collaboration
between different
agencies and ministries.
And we are expanding
this initiative
to support countries in Latin
America and the Caribbean.
And we're doing so with
the help of Google Cloud
and some credits that we're
getting through their Data
Solution for Change program.
And, in addition
to that, we have
partnered for the last
year with Google Cloud
to do a series of
SDG-related contests
in which we want
to get better ideas
and have attention on how to
bring solutions for the SDGs.
ELISSE ROCHE: Thanks, Alonso.
So, one of the SDG-related
contests that Alonso just
mentioned is Visualize 2030.
Visualize 2030-- data
stories for the SDGs--
is a data storytelling
contest for students
where we are students
from around the world
to analyze data sets
from the World Bank
and from the United
Nations Statistics Division
to visualize that data
using Google Data Studio
and to, ultimately, tell
a data-driven story about
how at least two of the
Sustainable Development Goals
influence each other and how
we can achieve them by 2030.
There's an interesting backstory
behind this contest as well.
So, Alonso mentioned the Data
for Development Festival,
before and that was, in
part, the inspiration
for the Visualize 2030 contest.
At that festival,
there were a lot
of talks in sessions about the
importance of democratizing
access to data, about
inviting everyone to the table
and making this data accessible
and consumable by everyone.
And data visualization has
a big part to play in that.
And that's essentially
what led to the ideation
around this contest and bringing
it to life later that year
in 2018.
For the applicants, the top
five eligible submissions
were to receive a $10,000
cash prize, an announcement,
and promotion by Google Cloud.
We also were working with
the World Bank and also
the United Nations Foundation
to make this possible.
So, again, thinking about what's
at the heart of the Global
Partnership for sustainable
development data-- there's
this idea of cooperation
and building bridges.
And this is definitely also
at the heart of this contest.
We also worked with an
expert panel of judges
in order to select the final
five winners, including
Rajesh Mirchandani
chief communications
officer of the United
Nations Foundation,
Claire Melamed, who is the CEO
of the Global Partnership team,
Haishan Fu, a director
at the World Bank,
Richard Curtis, who is a
writer-director and co-founder
of the Red Nose Day.
You also may be familiar with
some of his popular films
like "Love Actually."
Cindi Howson, who, at the
time, was a VP at Gartner,
Fausto Ibarra, director
of product management
with Google Marketing
platform, and Simon Rogers--
data editor at the
News Lab at Google.
So, with this expert
panel of judges,
we were really looking
to bring together
variety of expertise areas
together from sustainable
development to communications
to data storytelling
in order to assess the
finalists and determine, again,
these top five winners.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: So,
these are the five students
who submitted the most
compelling SDG data stories.
Actually, with us, we have
Evan, Kelsey, and Sarah.
Could you please
raise your hands?
Just a round of applause me.
[APPLAUSE]
They come from
different backgrounds,
are specializing
different topics,
and some are doing
undergraduate studies
and some are graduate students.
However, through
storytelling and design,
they all provided
compelling ways and stories
in which to talk about the SDGs.
And their ideas could
have real world impact,
and we hope they
don't stop here.
What stood out amongst
all of the submissions--
the winning submissions--
is that they also
found these
relationships between how
one goal affects the other.
And positive changes in one
to benefits on others and vice
versa.
So, Anisa is a master's student
of interactive journalism
at City University of London.
She focused on SDG5
and SDG16 which
are gender equality,
peace, justice,
and strong institutions
respectively.
She explored the relationship
between increased
female participation and
less corruption and stronger
institutions.
She zoomed in Rwanda's data as
an example of positive change.
So, Anna is a student
at UC-Berkeley's master
of information and
data science program.
She focused on SDG3,
SDG4, SDG5, and SDG8,
which are good home and
well-being, quality education,
gender equality, decent
work, and economic growth,
respectively.
She explores these
dimensions across a variety
of civilizations to make the
case that gender equality must
be embedded in core social
structures to have an impact.
And that, as a
result, other areas
that rely on these
same structures
will have positive gains.
Evan is a commerce student
at McMaster University.
He focused on SDG1--
no poverty-- and SDG13--
climate action.
He walked us through
the story of how,
as middle countries
begin to catch up
with high income states,
the resource, consumption,
and CO2 contributions
exponentially increase.
He used data to back
up his recommendations
and provided useful ways
to engage on these issues.
ELISSE ROCHE: So, another one
of the finalists, Kelsey Wang,
developed a data story called
"The Inequalities of Today
and Tomorrow" where
she focused on how
education can help to address
both poverty and climate
change--
looking at SDGs 1, 4, and 13.
She began her data
story with a question--
are people doing better
or worse than before?
How can we compare the
past to the present?
A very loaded
question, of course.
But, from there, she dug
deeper into the expansion
of the human population
which, as of 2017,
is over 7 billion people--
and also changes
in life expectancy.
And, looking at
those two variables
to think about the
unintended consequences
that come from that--
for example, industrial
agriculture and land
scarcity as well.
Especially with increases
in income inequality,
Kelsey made the case that
education and internet
technologies can actually act
as an equalizer across the world
and also serve to
empower individuals
around how they can take
action around climate change.
At the end of her
story, Kelsey concluded
that quality
education for everyone
is a building block for a
better, more sustainable,
and more equitable future.
Sarah Liou, in her
data story titled,
"Earth, Water, Air, and
Rising Temperatures"
focused on a total
of four SDGs--
so not just two, but four.
Specifically SDG2 on zero
hunger, SDG6, clean water
and sanitation, SDG13
around climate action,
and SDG15, life on land.
So, as you can
see pictured here,
Sarah developed an
interactive roadmap
to sustainable development,
really analyzing the effects
that agriculture has upon
the environment from land
use to water scarcity.
She assessed agricultural
greenhouse gas emissions
over time, changes in land
use and also livestock, waste
management-- so really
looking at these variables
holistically.
In addition, she presented a
case study on Madagascar land
use and how nearly
800 mammal species
are threatened by agriculture
and habitat loss today.
Another case study
explored in this data story
was that of Ethiopia,
where in 2016, over 90%
of available fresh water was
used for agricultural purposes.
Overall, Sarah made the case
for sustainable agriculture
as key to combating climate
change, fostering life on land,
providing clean water and
sanitation to everyone,
and concluded with a call
to action for everyone
to practice more
sustainable habits,
including limiting
meat consumption
and supporting urban farming.
So, with that, we would like
to say there is an opportunity
to learn more about our
respective organizations
and these initiatives,
starting with the Global
Partnership for Sustainable
Development Data.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: So, we're
an organization-based network.
So, if you're interested
in becoming part of us,
all the information is
available on our website.
I would also want to
invite you to check out
our Twitter account--
DataforSDGs-- and to
subscribe to our newsletter.
We really strive to provide
interesting information
and ways to engage not
only with a partnership
but also with a whole network.
ELISSE ROCHE: And, for more
information on Data Solutions
for Change, including the
nonprofit stories and just
exciting information around you
how-- if you're a non-profit,
how you can access this
program, how you can apply,
you can visit cloud.google.com
/DataSolutionsforChange
pictured here--
and also, to learn more about
Visualize 2030 and the winners
themselves.
You can also explore their
interactive data stories
within the Google
Data Studio tool.
You can visit
cloud.google.com/Visualize2030.
And, again, just another note
to wrap this session before we
open to questions-- and very
much encouraging questions--
is that what is key across
all these initiatives
and what we've
discussed today, again,
is this idea of cooperation--
of looking across industries
and really looking
at what can everyone
bring to the table
in these initiatives.
There are experts across a
variety of different areas--
whether that's biodiversity
or food systems or even
students working around
data visualization and data
analysis-- and working together
and making these opportunities
available, we can accomplish
some pretty exciting things
and work towards addressing
some of the world's greatest
challenges.
[MUSIC PLAYING]